jojo was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video zusammen
mit luca sebastian und wir haben uns
heute was überlegt und zwar sebastian
und sieben unterschiedliche artikel die
man irgendwo auf der welt kaufen kann
herausschaut
wir wollen den video auf der gala für
keine kirchensteuer asheville was hat
uns sieben unterschiedliche sachen
rausgesucht und wird uns die zeigen und
luca nicht raten wie viel das jeweilige
ding kostet wie viel das kostet und der
länder näher dran ist kriegt einen punkt
und der gewinner der gewinner kriegt von
verlierern eis ausgegeben
um was geht es um die schule um die hose
oder um nächste stadt es geht um den
pulli luca willst du die erste schätzung
abgeben okay ich schätze wenn jetzt
schon raus tut ist es bestimmt teuer
nein geschätzte 350 euro
ich glaube die farben sehen aus wie die
form von ms glaube ich dass das 800
europas 300 sagst du ich seit 250 350
und 800 sebastian ist also auch des
weges tatsächlich von dem es sehr gut
erkannt und es kostet 900 euro erster
punkt für max irgendwann musste es
merken jetzt eine einzelne firma hat die
nächste sache ist ein absolutes
schnäppchen und zwar ich habe schon
alltag trotzdem an ist es ein rolls
royce die erste station machen
abwechslung
ich schätze 5 millionen euro ich hab
schon mal bei mobile gesehen zwei
millionen das ist ein bugatti ich werde
nichts sagen
ein bugatti royale kellner coupé und der
wurde 1987 für 74 millionen euro
verkauft
die maschine sei verkauft also neu
gebaut wurden 21 gibt keinen plan davon
aber 87
der für 75 millionen euro auf 374 mio
ich bin froh dass die nächste sache
passt gut denn wir sind hier an der
nordsee
es geht um das hier dieses häuschen
dieses häuschen
das sind ich habe ich eine infos sind 30
quadratmeter wie war das denn
ja das ist die frage das ist hier vorher
mit kleinen wohn schick ist dabei also
ein großes grundstück 2 530 quadratmeter
haus bereits mit der haus also das
kassenhaus an sich wahrscheinlich eher
nada wäre also ein halbe million bei
aller analyse 30 uhr ja nun habe ich
auch aber die baufläche stein pornos auf
sylt so viel baufläche das wäre gut aber
man muss beides desto nicht so viel
bauen darf das sind dass du nicht einmal
alles bebauen davos okay ich sage was
ist unser 15 millionen ich sag 5
millionen 5 millionen und das grundstück
das haus steht in kampen und 30
quadratmeter wie gesagt grundstück
millionen verdammt netter und kostet
beziehungsweise steht gerade zum verkauf
für 63 millionen euro 6m stück wenn ich
noch eins haben ja drei combos erst habe
ich kenne mich überhaupt nicht mit
marken aus dem sommer schon heute also
ich glaube ich ich erkenne jetzt auch
keine grosse marken converse oder so ich
würde sagen 15 euro
15 euro oder 16 euro ok kurz gefasst der
rucksack ist nicht von converse und max
mit 15 war etwas weniger entfernt als
luca vom tatsächlichen kaufpreis und 630
euro aus plastik 36 euro das ist richtig
stört oder ok also nicht was als
nächstes das was man vielleicht öfter
sieht als eine moschee turnbeutel und
zwar bis jetzt richtig eng so ein eur 53
selbst eingekauft
aber schuld genau anschaut was wir nix
ist orange blossom hanni leicht und
sonstwas sieben euro fast 150 150 jahre
gut daran merken dass die holy einkaufte
steht ist nämlich finanziell sehr teuer
und dass ihr dieser orange plattform hd
kostet elf euro 91
dieses ist übrigens der besten
weltrekordhalter hier wurde im örtlichen
supermarkt erschossen gerade eben zwar
handelt es sich um diese köstlichkeit
sie um grad wollte ich sagen dass h&m
eigentlich so gar nichts
anfangs sechs euro 50 56 66 106 5 32 32
diese ahornsirup aus dem örtlichen
supermarkt kostet sechs euro
90990 33 es wird zu knapp 1 million
aufrufe
ich muss mir noch einmal durch auf den
standpunkt machen könnte
ich habe drei jahre alte christian reitz
holt gold bei einer million auf
christian reitz einmal schlagen fuß
christiane frei machen jetzt weit
beträgt mir fallen zwischen 33
diese sache jetzt kommt mich geschossen
in der lage zum 82 kilo toblerone zwei
kilo toblerone 22 22
es sind zwei kilogramm dieses dreht und
zu einzelverkaufspreis 20 mal 1 zu
verkaufen weiß ich muss an dem tipp gebe
ich euch noch mal 22 mal 12
wir müssen jetzt den preis schätzen für
eine kleine packung alle für 20 20 20
punkte 20 100 gramm packung 155 euro 55
euro für zwei kleine finale
solches einen langen langen 250
eigentlich hey du
den stein auf den kopf zwei kilo 25 euro
schätzt 50 euro okay ich schätze 40
schätzt 40 euro 40 euro von mir
40 jahre steht bei 40 euro lust bei 55
euro und der preis für die tonne im
lokalen supermarkt
ich dachte das war's von haltingen video
laden so leute das war's vom heutigen
video ich hoffe mal das war heute wieder
lasst mal ein like da erst mein abo da
schreibt was in die kommentare
und ja das war das macht's gut